[Music]
wouldn't it be awesome at the barista at
your local coffee shop remembered your
name and your usual brew if you are
building an application you may want to
build that kind of tailored experience
for your users to make them feel special
or save them time of course no matter
how great your idea is the success of
your app depends on your ability to
build trust with your users which comes
down to securing your users data and
protecting the system that your app
accesses knowing who is using your app
is a key part of this which starts with
adding sign-in functionality but as a
lot of developers now adding
authentication and authorization to your
app is both risky and complex that's why
we build app ID of IBM cloud app ID
helps developers to easily add
authentication to their mobile and web
apps and hosts user data in the cloud
that developers can use to build custom
app experiences to make the sign-in
experience easy for your users with app
ID you can let users sign up directly
from your app and then sign in with
their email and password or you can let
users sign in through their Facebook and
Google accounts with credentials they
already know once your users
authenticate you can authorize access to
back-end resources that your app uses
app ID also helps you deliver tailored
experiences for your users based on a
variety of factors like their app
preferences and I buy these you can sort
information about your users and let
developers use this info for their apps
app ID is available for iOS Android and
the web and of course it is built with
open standards like oh ah - and oh I DC
to get started check out the app ID
service in the IBM cloud catalog
[Music]